my beautiful daughter Onyx that's
probably the child that I spend the most
time with Nick Cannon opening up about
which of his 12 children gets the most
quality time I was always like yo I want
a big family too so you know the Lord
has blessed me with what I asked but
you're asking you shall receive the star
gets real about how he balances his time
between all his kids during a recent
appearance on the Jason Lee show
revealing it's his eight-month-old
daughter Onyx whom he shares with
Lanisha Cole that's got most of his
attention these days I'm with her at
least three times a week for the full
day Lanisha and I have a super strong
understanding in our co-parenting
operation is is so solid but you know if
you see me on Mondays Wednesdays or
Fridays my daughter is right next to me
not against all my other kids because
all of my other kids they're in school
their you know their babies but that as
well as Onyx but the fact that I
appreciate that Lanisha gives me their
respect enough to allow me to to have
her you know really is as equal amount
of time as she does it's not as
difficult as people think it would be
but I understand because it's a very
unorthodox scenario but it actually I
mean I dedicate probably my entire day
to my children and next got quite the
family tree kids you know I got a lot of
them in addition to Onyx he has three
kids with Abby Delarosa six-month-old
beautiful and one-year-old twins Zion
and zillion he's also Father to 12 year
old twins Moroccan and Monroe with
Mariah Carey six-year-old golden
two-year-old powerful and
eight-month-old rise with Brittany Bell
10 month old legendary with breed CAC
I'm a whole human I'm responsible for it
he shares five-month-old Halo with
Alyssa Scott in their late sons in while
the internet has plenty to say about
Nick's large family the TV personality
explains why his untraditional lifestyle
works for him luckily we're in a world
where my light and I I might have said
this and was misquoted before but I was
like I get I'm blessed with the
opportunity I get to spend more time
with my children every single day
because of my world and my business my
life and Bree's been getting lots of
heat too with her co-parenting
relationship with Nick becoming a Hot
Topic during her debut on Netflix's
selling Sunset your journey to
Motherhood became a Hot Topic
Chelsea is kind of the most vocal
about you she is
she has a lot to say ultimately the way
I live my life is very different to her
as a Christian she says that she can't
really support your choices because of
her faith
it's kind of comical to me to be honest
especially someone that says that they
have faith and are a Christian
I grew up it was you turn the other
cheek and we don't judge and all those
things she can have whatever opinion she
wants I just wish she kept a little bit
of it to herself because we're happy so